maximum a very difficult game for you
you are on minus one and after the
opening uh it was a difficult position
he was putting a lot of pressure on you
but your your resilient self and managed
to turn it around how do you feel right
now
of course it feels great to to win I
didn't like my position at all I don't
know where I went wrong in the opening
but the sun game turned out to be a lot
more difficult to play than I thought at
first
and
then I found a setup that I didn't like
at all with this Knight on B7 let's take
a look but at least
so I surprised you with this a lot yeah
yeah they set up and I didn't expect at
all
when's the last time you checked the
Laughing no I checked it I check it on
occasions really yeah yeah like not in
this tournament but I definitely checked
it last year like maybe even this year
so yeah but still it's difficult to
remember the details yeah and well and
he was also playing extremely fast yeah
extremely fast and quite well because I
just thought here I should be all right
but then after night fd2 I realized yeah
it's not so easy because
yeah
probably the suggestion by computer to
play A5 I didn't want to commit to A5
but turned out in the game I had to so
I play Knight F6 Knight B3
yeah what was it about the position that
you didn't feel comfortable with no
simply
it keeps all the pieces
my points are sometimes weak and I don't
have so much space for my from a minor
piece so
yeah I really didn't like it at all so
that's why I decided at some point to
just allow a pair of Bishops and try to
get some content play with this Knight
C5
play with the Knights yeah and this was
early but
had to be done had to be done
and at this point
it looks innocuous right you open up the
age file but it doesn't seem like you're
doing anything on no it doesn't but then
suddenly
it did so anyway like my plan was to
exchange perfect anyway I want Rook d8
for instance I have Bishop E7 I guess I
want from C7 he played a bit carelessly
like very fast also to put pressure on
time but yeah suddenly
it becomes tough because and Bishop D6 I
realize I have Knight D7 and here I saw
Bishop C7 he has to pay a lot but of
course it's tempting to continue playing
yeah yeah Bishop C7 I take and take I
play F6 I thought maybe maybe I'm even
trying I mean I I didn't think so but
like my knight is coming to C5 so it's
very pleasant
and uh if Bishop p7 yeah Knight E5
Bishop G5 I thought this was quite
important but it just wins yeah
very nice and then after B3 I mean at
first like I saw this move but I didn't
consider it seriously and that was a bit
done on time so I was feeling I should
have instead of taking walks maybe but I
was expecting Bishop C7 at the same time
so
um and that's quite unusual for you
you're not very often in time travel
situation was
so anyway
then I realized I have F6 and yeah when
I saw that after Bishop ace high of 95
and suddenly like normally it felt like
you know when I exchanged Bishop against
Knight his Knight on G2 is covering
everything but once my opponent is on E5
which seems ridiculous at First Sight
but then I always get E4 and the Knight
on B7 gets into play and then well I
don't know because I I don't know if it
was always winning if he had a draw like
this eye really don't know but at the
very least when it got weird and you
thought for a while I realized yeah I'm
winning with this hook H3 check at the
end quite important so interesting right
because after Rook to D6
I was trying I was looking uh in the
playing hole at the position and in fact
I had no idea how to assess it and then
I come back and I see minus 3.6 on the
engine
to lose first of all and that's I have
what looks like a decisive attack like
so you assessed it as much better for
yeah probably winning but of course I
had to prove it and it was not that easy
yeah to integrate
I mean today
and to intricate all the details but
can you repeat it once very professional
just because Jan got up so I thought I'm
gonna win time
that's very professional yeah yes the
route takes B6 take on F3 be careful not
to get checkmated on G2 yeah
and when was it clear for you was at
this point I would assume you were
already kind of sure about the victory I
mean I was not completely sure first of
all there was a Muslim King history but
I knew I I knew that you know his ponds
were stopped and but yeah and I mean I
have I need okay so I think okay to draw
no me actually not I thought I thought
it was
um well then
uh
unnecessary for which but of course it's
nice to to bring his King to F2 yeah
Maxim uh a big victory with the black
pieces and especially sweeter whenever
you win against such a strong opponent
such as Jan he's a world championship
Challenger twice he has a luggage filled
with opening preparation
um congratulations we'll see you in a
couple of days thank you guys thank you
question then our congratulations to MBL
uh wow